[Music]
[Music]
life can be
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
me
don't you baby
[Music]
no i ain't gonna push
[Music]
come on come on
thank you
all right come on
now we say good is it good evening
i guess it's good evening
i've got mayor pro tim dave martin with
me and chief penion
and the chief medical officer of the
city dr purse and
major zach bale with the salvation army
and
a number of people that are with me
today now look good
good evening to everyone and thank you
for joining us i know it's
it's later than what this press
conference would normally be
but there were a number of mayors from
across the country that was on a
call with president-elect biden and
president
vice president kamala harris today and
that was
this afternoon right around two o'clock
and then after that
i had a meeting with a number of the big
city mayors in the state of texas
discussing a number of topics um some of
which were talking about today
so that delayed us quite a bit i'm also
joined by uh
again dr purse she's pina and mayor pro
tem
in just a few days families across our
city stating
country would gather to give thanks for
the many blessings
we have experienced but it goes without
saying that thanksgiving day
is going to look and feel a lot
different
than in previous years and it should uh
because of the coronavirus
it is not safe for people to gather in
large groups or to sit down at the table
with people
outside of their immediate households
and remember what we've said many times
we don't want to invite covert to your
thanksgiving table
the virus is still spreading and
hospitalizations are increasing
and i want you to know every day that
i've looked at them our numbers have
gone in terms of hospitalizations
uh from from the low 400s and then
five hundreds then the six and the seven
hundreds and now it's in the low
800s so it's the numbers are uh steadily
creeping up
and we need to be mindful of that i
cannot ex
stress enough that the numbers are
moving uh upwards the positivity rate
for this week is 8.8 percent
in the city of houston uh that is up
from last week 7.9
so this week is at 8.8 and let me ask
for your help i need your help
in helping us to blunt that curve from
going up
if nothing else to stabilize it and then
to work to start bringing it down
but the number is going up and it's
going up free
thanksgiving and so that's why we are uh
encouraging people
this thanksgiving season uh to resist
the temptation to come together in large
groups large gatherings
especially family gatherings uh that is
that's not
that is not in anyone's best interest or
right now
uh the houston health department reports
463
uh new cases of cobit 19 uh bringing
houston's total count
to 93 988.
uh we're also today reporting uh
three uh people who have died uh from
covet 19
and that will bring the city's total to
1417.
i will say as of today we're still in a
situation
a manageable situation on this virus but
as you know this virus can go from zero
to 60
real quickly and therefore we're asking
people
uh to be mindful of your behavior
be mindful of who you're going to be uh
hanging out with over the next
uh several days and join with us
uh to blunt the progression of this
virus
right now i'm not even asking for it to
go down to five percent i'm just asking
us to keep from raising the positivity
rate up
just to blunt it right where it is and
then let's start
working to bring it down until we get a
vaccine
our mass is our vaccine this one
right here that's the max that's the
vaccine we must continue to mess up
social distance wash our hands
frequently and get
tested to reinforce the message today
uh i'm announcing the launch of a new
and second
massive commercial last time
we used some star athletes and a rapper
and this time i have a little help from
my friends
um all of the mascots from our houston
area sports teams
along with denzel washington denzel will
be the one in the apron
let's see let's see if we can get denzel
and the others to join us
we need to be mindful of everyone's
health and safety
when planning family gatherings make a
plan
and share it with your guests get tested
at one of the many free
testing sites within the city continue
to be vigilant
wear your mask wash your hands
frequently and social distance
so you can enjoy your time together with
peace of mind
protecting our loved ones is the most
important thing for all of us
mask up houston we're better together
when planning family gatherings be
prepared get
tested wash your hands frequently and
social distance
protecting our loved ones is the most
important thing for all of us
mask up houston we're better together
[Music]
in mascara
all right we want to thank those houston
mascots and we want to thank denzel
uh for um appearing in that commercial
no charge i might ask you
add to that and then i want to thank
susan christian and her team for
code for directing and producing so
thank you susan christian
for that and that's susan i will own so
a lot of a lot of talent right here at
the city of houston
i want to thank all the houston texans
the houston rockets and the houston
dynamos
and daesh for loaning us their mascots
to assist with the campaign
to encourage houstonians to continue to
safeguard themselves from
potential exposure to cobit 19.
uh quickly before i bring up dr purse
who will talk
more about the vaccination protocols and
and chi pena also will talk about what's
happening in his shop
i want to welcome our friends from the
salvation army and mention the red
kettle challenge
day since 19 since 1889 the salvation
army of greater houston has provided the
services
of feeding sheltering emotional and
spiritual care
substance abuse programs child care and
emergency disaster relief
to those who need the help the most in
our communities
this year with social discipline rules
in place
the salvation army's iconic red kettles
we expect to see a sharp decline in
donations
due to decreased foot traffic at grocery
stores
malls and other brick and mortar martyr
institutions this christmas season the
devastation caused by this downturn
will be felt by not only the
organization the salvation army
but also those that they serve this
includes the homeless
the the hungry the abuse the addicted
and the forgotten the salvation army is
predicting a 155
increase in need this season that's 155
need increase they need our help to
serve our neighbors in the city
so the salvation army has launched their
red kettle
online and has challenged the community
to help them
rescue christmas unquote for those
in need and though we haven't been able
to partake in some traditions
ringing in the season with the salvation
army's red kettle
is something we want we wanted to give
the community
today i'm presenting a proclamation to
major zach
bell and i am honored to officially ring
in the season
ring in the season and proclaim that the
fourth
friday of every november marks the start
of the red kettle season
and so um with that in mind
major bell
let me take this opportunity to present
uh to you
the red federal challenge this
proclamation and and in five degrees
therefore
that's the turn of mayor city of houston
hereby proclaim november 27
2020 as red kettle challenged me
in the city of houston thank you all for
what your opportunity to do
have some few remarks
i won't take long i'll just say this i
just want to thank houston in advance
for what you're going to do
because we believe that the city of
houston we are a community
who rallies around those in need we see
that need each and every day at the
salvation army
just know that that bell ringing is a
call that we you can come and help and
serve those at their greatest time of
need
thank you so much god bless you and
merry christmas on behalf of the
salvation army
i kind of like this bill
all right don't forget the salvation
army so many people rely on them for
their support
and even though the foot traffic may not
be as as
as great as it has been in previous
years the need
is even greater 155 percent increase
in need this year so again uh when you
see the cattle
or go online and if you see the cattle
police give
and if for example if you hear me ring
the bell
that means donations are accepted okay
to the salvation army
uh now at this point in time let me call
on dr purse the chief medical officer
for the city
thank you mayor as the mayor pointed out
the
numbers we're seeing are increasing uh
daily and as you also pointed out we
monitor those numbers
on a daily basis we get them both from
the texas medical center as well as from
stetrak which looks at it in a per
county basis so we of course pay close
attention
to um harris county now i believe
there's a chart that's coming up
no okay well anyways the mayor talked
about you can see on the side that he
showed earlier you could see that the
the the numbers were rising now one of
the things that i want to point out in
that slide is the numbers that are
rising now
if you go back you look at late june
then you would see that well you can see
here the numbers are going up our
positivity rate is is going up now our
numbers are not where we were
a while back we were higher than this
but the movement is in the same wrong
direction i also want to point out that
the height of those yellow and red bars
indicates the number of people who are
getting tested and i want to thank
houstonians
because the number of folks getting
tested is up a little bit over 60
percent
just in the last few weeks so people are
responding and then this is really
uh uh this is really good for the
reasons we've said many many times one
is it gives us better insight
into what's going on in the community
number two for the people who get tested
if you should
be one of the 40 or more percent people
who are infected and don't have any
symptoms and therefore you wouldn't have
any way to otherwise know
once you've tested and you find out your
positive you are now in a position where
you can protect your family from the
virus
that you are unknowingly carrying so the
fact the more people are going test it
is
is
really really great we're we're glad to
see that and it's also
unfortunately showing that the virus is
spreading at the numbers are are going
up we're at 8.8
which is not a small number when we talk
about
um across harris county and the number
of hospitalizations that are occurring
the the number of hospital beds that are
currently occupied with patients
diagnosed with coba disease
has risen to over 10 percent is now 10.4
percent
so that's a threshold we hope that we
would not meet you may recall
that the governor has set a threshold
that uh for a
trauma service area and for us it's a
nine county region if it gets about 15
percent the rules sort of change
the state level so for the state level
you know they're seeing 15
we are we are uh unfortunately we're on
track to hit that if we don't change
something so we need to take advantage
the time we have now to start driving
these numbers numbers down again 10.4
percent
is uh very high i believe we are down as
low as six percent uh several several
weeks ago
and then in terms of the vaccine the
mayor point out we're gonna be talking
about the vaccine we're expecting that
there will be vaccine coming out in the
next several weeks
um we're unclear so exactly when that's
gonna be have to wait for some decisions
to be made at the at the federal level
but when they will be sent out they're
going to be prioritized and the governor
today
uh issued a um a statement illustrating
the priorities
that have been said at the state level
in terms of what the
the the philosophy will be is how that
vaccine will remember in the beginning
we'll probably have less vaccine than
there are people who are wanting it
and it um so we need to prioritize that
so the number one you can see the
priorities that are here that are listed
uh on this slide these come from the the
governor's
uh task force and then we'll be
protecting health care workers but in
particular these are health care workers
who are in the practice of caring for
coveted positive patients
not just any and all health care workers
but those that are
in the hospitals taking care of covet
patients and the immediate support
personnel
who are involved in the care of patients
who currently are diagnosed with cova
disease
um also going to be looking at
vulnerable populations
we're looking at other frontline workers
who are at increased risk because of
what they do
so i want you to picture the people who
work on ambulances
that are be transporting covid patients
uh the vulnerable populations
and then of course uh going beyond
specific populations talking about
the process will be once we're going to
look to mitigate health inequities
these will be data-driven decisions
there will be some geographic
appropriate geographic dispersity just
i'm sorry diversity
and then there's going to be uh
transparency on the part of all the uh
to the public of all the allocations
this is the the priorities set forth by
the governor
and we are fortunate that our own
stephen williams the director of the
city's health department was on a
committee that uh
helped with this um as the vaccine
becomes available locally
it will be first sent to hospitals
because the number one priority here as
i mentioned is going to be healthcare
workers in the practice of caring for
covered patients
uh it will also be going to some of the
other as more vaccine comes available go
to some of the other usual vaccination
sites so with that i want you to start
thinking of your primary care physicians
offices
i want you to think of the fairly
qualified health care center clinics
things along those lines where vaccines
are normally
made available the houston health
department will serve our role that we
always serve
as being that safety net provider so
that we'll be able to provide vaccine to
those who have no
no other way of getting it and again we
will be prioritizing
those communities that have increased
risk and
less availability uh due to all kinds of
health care inequities so we're very
familiar with
where those neighborhoods are but we'll
also be monitoring where the virus
activity is at any given time
and try to prioritize those
neighborhoods uh to that end
in getting vaccine out in the community
we have been we the houston health
department working with providers across
the region
we've already identified 333
houston healthcare providers which are
identified as cobot vaccine providers
and we work with harris county there's
another 250 vaccine providers within the
county
that are already registered to
participate in the vaccination program
and uh in the meantime however i want to
remind folks
that until you become vaccinated and
remember the vaccines
most of them it's like two two dose two
shots
um until you get backstage it's actually
a week after your second dose
that you would be able to consider
yourself and this is going to take a
while
until then we all need to continue
wearing our masks washing our hands
remaining physically distant and doing
all the things and that the
that our mascots are showing us how to
do and protecting ourselves just as we
have been
here thank you i know there are probably
a few questions coming back to you dr
purse
chief kenya
thank you mayor good afternoon everyone
i'm going to provide a quick update on
the fire department's uh quarantine
numbers
um and then i will do a spanish
translation on what the doctor purse had
just
mentioned and what the mayor related
earlier the quarantine numbers for the
houston fire department today
are we have 125 firefighters that are in
quarantine
we've had since the pandemic began we've
had 340 firefighters that have tested
positive
for coronavirus 296 of those have since
returned to work
currently we have 43 firefighters that
are that are
in quarantine um
as we expect the the holiday season
coming up
and especially thanksgiving i want to
remind our community of
just a few safety uh reminders
especially
cooking and frying reminders okay
fried turkeys are delicious
you can they really are you can fry a
shoe and it'll taste good so turkeys are
even
better but i want to remind the public
that it is very dangerous
if you do it improperly please follow
the proper directions make sure your
the turkey is fully thawed and dried
before you dip it into that hot oil
do not fry your turkeys inside your home
your garage
or on your deck or under the eaves they
have to be away from the home
please away from the home and and
outside so uh
that's a quick reminder but every year
we see
a number of fires resulting from cooking
accidents
um if you can put the slide back up what
the doctor had uh the summary of the
governor's
order and i'll summarize that in spanish
real quick
um
that was very good and you covered all
of those points that i wanted you to
cover
um left out of one of two things but
i'll amplify that a little bit later on
um and then speaking on behalf of city
council let me call on mayor pro tem
to just amplify the safety message
because of this
thanksgiving it could be either good or
it can be
very alarming for us after thanksgiving
so uh ma'am pro tem
thank you mayor if your family is a
traditional family like mine you have
someone coming home from college
hopefully they were tested before they
came home because we made ours do that
as well
and i know that our traditional
thanksgiving trip to another city isn't
going to happen so
the important thing this vaccine is on
the horizon and everybody needs to
understand that
so we have just a couple of months to
get through this tough time period so
make sure we all wear our mass social
distance and do the proper hygiene even
though we have thanksgiving which is a
very very focused on the family type of
holiday
i'm especially concerned with the
numbers that you see in the desk with
the hispanic community
because we know la familia very family
oriented
so for this time let's step back a
little bit and let's make sure we put in
the proper protocols to keep everybody
safe because
we don't want any more deaths in the
city of houston so
last thing happy thanksgiving and god
bless
thank you man pro tem before we open for
questions i want to acknowledge that
there
has been a lot of discussion about
houston area schools
seeing an increase in uh student failing
grace as a result of co-bit 19. i'm very
concerned from that uh coming from and
still living in an underserved community
and
kids that are falling behind as a result
of co-bed and the virtual learning
we have monitored the reopening of
schools across the city and have found
that a campus environment
is one of the safest places for our most
vulnerable historically underserved
student population a student's school is
often the only place where students can
feel safe from other environmental
factors
that impact their learning at home they
receive
critical wrap around support services
food access
counseling tutoring and more beyond
these essential services
school district leaders have indicated
that about 40 percent of students
are failing at least two core classes
compared to about seven to eight percent
we would see in a typical school year a
significant contributing factor to this
across the board decrease in student
performance
becomes apparent when a child is not
able to attend class in person
and many of our students especially
those who are low
income or need additional educational
support services
perform much worse online i'm reminded
of when
i was in school neither one of my
parents graduated from high school
and quite frankly they were not able to
assist me or in my homework when i got
home i can only imagine
uh parents who may find themselves in
similar situation
and kids as well and that is why
uh what i've indicated to dr purse and
to others
let's do everything we can to support
our schools our school districts
to make them as safe as possible for
that so that many of our kids can
continue to get in-person learning
that's critically important otherwise
this virus
will not only put them further behind
now
but it will impact their lives down the
road this necessitates our schools being
open for students who need
the most help getting back on track
of the kobit 19 cases we have seen in
our schools
most of the persons infected were
exposed to the virus outside of school
our educational leaders have gone to
great length to keep the inside of
school buildings as safe as possible
by requiring mass social discipline when
possible
ramping up cleaning and sanitation
services and
implementing holistic safety measures to
respond to any potential virus need
their dedication to safety has made our
campuses
safe and we want to continue to support
them every way possible
for our kids for our teachers cafeteria
workers
bus drivers you name it but this virus
has created
a a great deal of challenges and its
impact has just been
um unimaginable and the fact that many
of our kids are
falling behind is highly disturbing and
so
um we wanted to provide as much support
to our districts to our schools to our
parents teachers
support staff and to our children
because
to the extent they can be have in-person
learning
that is in their best interest and quite
frankly it's in
all of our best interests for today and
for tomorrow
so let's uh let's continue to provide
that needed support to them
as they continue their in-person
learning as much as possible
having said that we will take any
questions or comments that anyone may
have
let's start with the pool touring
followed by channel 13 and channel 2.
um
first questions to you mayor sure how's
how did today's discussion go with uh
president
the vice president-elect yeah it was it
was very it was a very good session the
very fact that
even before he sworn in that he would
take the time to meet with many of the
uh
um the mayors across the country
many uh from from the u.s conference of
mayors i'm one of the trustees and so he
met with almost all of the trustees
as well as some others it was quite
frankly an opportunity to ask both
uh the president-elect and as well as
the vice president-elect some questions
there were five mayors who asked
questions on behalf of all of us
so i thought that was quite informative
if he did indicate a willingness
to work directly with mayors on an
ongoing basis he recognized that we are
on the front line
recognize the needs that we are facing
from
vaccinations to infrastructure
to climate change the economy all of
those things
came up housing education those we
should they were very positive
so i thought it was a good start and
look forward to continuing to work with
him
uh were you able to address houston
specifically and if so
uh what did they talk about not today uh
houston didn't come up specifically
today but i can
tell you just based on other
conversations that there will be some
additional conversations
uh i have been in communication with the
uh transition representative uh
that's where houston has been assigned
to that particular person
so i've talked to that person several
times
over the last over the last couple of
weeks
and look forward to uh continuing those
uh those conversations um
you know look we want to do everything
we can to make sure that houston is on
the map
and when they are implementing their
policies uh that uh
houston is is kept front and center in
there
in their minds uh for the grb
turkey fest is there going to be
anything different for the people
receiving food
or and also uh is there going to be
anything different from
talking about the superfest that's the
superficial schedule for uh this coming
uh
thursday uh citywide clubs bishop
woodard
i think the difference this time um a
major difference
instead of their being served hot meals
because every year
you know my daughter myself and so many
other thousands of volunteers but they
are serving them
i think this time is going to be a
pickup and go
uh similar to what occurred at the nrg
this past
this past weekend uh there will be uh
where people can walk up and and take um
food with them or they can drive through
so that
will change from the hot meals uh it
will be different
a much safer way of distributing or
meeting people's needs this year
and is there any uh donations or
anything
still needed from the community with
that super feast they
literally feed oh anywhere from 20 to 25
000 i'm sure bishop would would be here
he would tell you they are still in need
of turkeys
and all of the canned goods and all of
the things that go right along with
providing the thanksgiving meal
and i say that because just today
separate apart from
the city-sponsored uh food distribution
that
susan uh christian and and uh
shannon bugs and the herd task force and
heb and all the other sponsors did on
saturday
just today alone i participated at three
different notebooks and three or four
three different food distributions just
today
on the south side as well as on the
north side each one of those locations
the lines were long
so there are tremendous needs even
in our city and we're not going to be
able to meet
all of those needs but let me tell you
what i'm glad you asked a question let
me tell you what i'm i'm thankful
for i'm thankful for the fact that so
many people
and businesses uh have been willing to
share
what they have with people who are less
fortunate than themselves
so much so that literally thousands
of families thousands of families in the
houston
houston region that their needs to some
degree
are being are being met so i'm very very
thankful for that
next question is for dr perch
i'm not exactly sure what that means but
should i get my wings
oh question is it's been nearly a week
since harris county
sent out a public alert to all residents
urging them to get tested for covet
what kind of traffic have you seen at
the test site since then
and what do the results tell you from
that so this is what we were talking
about before and the mayor put out an
alert
as well um so with that grabby side
there's been a steady increase
i wouldn't say there's actually a jump
after the judges but that was a good
thing that she put that out
but we have seen a steady increase in
people getting tested
and at the same time we've seen the
positivity rate going up now let's not
connect those two those are
two true statements one does not cause
the other more testing does not cause
more positive
percentage right it just makes sure that
it just allows us to have more
confidence that that 8.8 percent
value we have today is accurate and so
we've seen an increased number of folks
going getting tested which is good
gives us more confidence in that the
fact that we're seeing the percentage
positivity going up is accurate and
truthful
okay if someone who hasn't been in
quarantine
wanted to celebrate thanksgiving with
family
while wearing a mask is there a test
that a person could take
either at a sitting city testing site or
the hospital
that could give them accurate results
rapidly
all right so first of all i would not
recommend anybody go to a hospital to
get tested
hospitals are busy taking care of sick
people do not go to a hospital to get
tested there are plenty of testing sites
available throughout the community
most of those the results are going to
take two to three days
to get back so if you wanted to go and
get tested you need to do it today
or tomorrow right those are the ones the
pcr tests there are rapid tests that are
available throughout the community some
places are offering those but i would
warn you that the positive results in
those are reliable
there are very few false positives most
of those pauses are very reliable but
unfortunately in people who don't have
any symptoms
the um the asymptomatic people there's a
fairly respectable false
negative rate so there's rapid tests
where you can answer in 15 to 30 minutes
are really only helpful if you get a
positive result
if you have no symptoms you get a
negative result you really should still
go on to get another test and the
problem is with thanksgiving being this
thursday
and today is monday people are running a
little bit short on time
and what would you say to the person
that's planning on taking
either an antigen antibody or pcr
test the wednesday before thanksgiving
all right so first of all the antibody
test um tells you whether you had the
disease a long time ago so the antibody
test don't help you at all
right now really uh the antigen and the
pcr test
look for acute infection uh but really
the question you're asking about is the
timeline i think i just kind of answered
that if you want to get one of those
tests you really need to get it done
today or tomorrow and then the other
thing is um even if you
even if you were to get the test and
it's negative remember
particularly people who are without
symptoms
that one of the one of the problems is
that you can get a false negative and so
this graphic here
which i think uh thank gosh we've got it
so handy
so this is a graphic showing if if
somebody were to become infected on day
one
and they are infected on day one they
get exposed they now have the virus
remember for the first 24 to 48 hours
they're probably not going to have any
symptoms and for the first 24 hours they
may not be spreading it
but even as late as day 5 they could
test negative and that be a false
negative because it's so
early on since they got infected they
would be negative and so in this graphic
on day eight is thanksgiving
they go and they infect their family
members because now by that time they're
shedding virus they still have no
symptoms
on day 10 they start feeling a little
lousy got a cough got a little fever
body ache they go and get tested
they now come back test positive they
now are at a point where the test will
be positive but unfortunately two days
later
they unknowingly and unwittingly
admittedly but unknowingly
potentially infected their family
members so a lot of this is timing it's
not always necessarily intuitive it's
it's a little bit inconvenient but these
are the facts
that's right
hi um and this question for you as well
uh dr purse uh
i was wondering if you could just sort
of as an example for people tell us what
you and your families are going to be
doing for thanksgiving this year
yeah so i'll tell you what my family so
in my family we've not seen our
grandchildren since january
so they're going to come over everyone's
going to stay outside
my wife and i are gonna be inside we're
gonna be cooking preparing the meal
um we have two daughters one of which is
a uh active public health person and
she's gonna be the sheriff
and she doesn't know this yet and if
she's watching courtney you're the
sheriff
and your job is to be the mask police
and the distancing police and we're
going to celebrate outdoors
and uh um and do it that way so it'll be
outdoors
everybody's gonna wear a mask and we've
got plenty of room outside in the
backyard for us to be able to do it so
that's
that's what we're doing but um quite
honestly that's only because we
have not seen our grandchildren since
january because
all this time we've been playing by the
rules and i don't think that we're
violating the rules
we're going to be very strictly adhering
to them but that's what my family's
doing
all right
our family my wife and i have three kids
our oldest and his wife are expecting
our first grandchild
so we're very concerned about the
effects of covid19 on a fetus because
nobody can give me any date on that
so fortunately for us uh he's a doctor
in the medical center and he has to work
on thanksgiving day
so that other people that have kids and
can experience that with their families
can do it so
for us our oldest son is at university
of texas in austin and he came home
yesterday and we required him to get a
toe covered test before he came home
so my wife is we call her the queen of
corona
like that song because she does
everything by the book
she never goes to a restaurant never
goes out never does anything
so we're keeping the spirit of social
distancing proper hygiene and making
sure that
it's only our immediate family and we
know that they're negative
so we're doing the very best that we can
and we hope every other family in the
city
i don't know what we're doing actually
thank you very much
thank you very much for that profound
statement
[Laughter]
and for the turtle household uh we're
gonna
my daughter and i will be attending the
super feast first
uh we go there every year so even though
it's being reimagined
uh we will still start off our morning
with the uh
city of clubs bishop butter and his
group at the super feast
and then uh noon uh uh my daughter will
bring
will bring over the desserts that she
will be making
uh and then i'm having some food catered
uh but it's just going to be a very
small gathering and then later on that
day
my uh one of my other sisters will be
dropping off some food
you know we're not going to be getting
together my mom's
like we would normally get it will be
different
so um one sister is going to be dropping
off some food the other is going to be
dropping off
and um we will say until until next year
so it will be it will be different there
will be no gathering
in acres home and my mom and dad's both
are deceased but we always
gather uh in anchorage home we will
we're not going to do that this time
around
um because we recognize that everyone
wants to be safe and want to live to see
another day
and so uh that's exactly what we're
going to do
thank you all for sharing that and i
have more questions for you dr purse
about
vaccine distribution you mentioned the
health department as being sort of a
safety net
for vaccines could you talk more about
what you mean by that and can people
just depend on
going to the health department and
getting a vaccine and do you know
anything about
cost yet would it be free yeah good good
so the cost
uh at this point we're anticipating
there being no cost the federal
government said they're going to cover
the cost not only for the vaccine but
for the supplies so the syringes the
swabs the needles so on and so forth
um there will be a cost and that we got
the manpower that we're going to have to
do that i think i don't i haven't heard
the federal government's gonna send us
any dollars to pay for man-hours so
but in terms of supplies in the vaccine
that should be at no cost
and so you know routinely when we have
uh vaccinations
you know all the routine vaccinations
there are people in our community
who don't have a primary care physician
and yet
you know they need vaccines or their
kids needs vaccines for school and so we
we fill that role now as this rolls out
and this is going to be evolving right
so it's very early so right now we know
that the vaccine as i mentioned is going
to be
predominantly going to hospitals and
frontline workers
and a lot of this remains to be worked
out but as it starts rolling out there's
more vaccine it starts getting further
and further out in the community
we anticipate it'll be going
predominantly to the usual
so the doctor's offices the clinics
those uh sorts of place where people
who have those resources but as i said
earlier we know full well that there are
people in the community who just don't
have access to that
or um you know there are other issues
whether it be transportation
or what have you there are people coming
up with you know challenges that they
can't overcome on their own and it's our
job
to figure out ways to get them the
vaccine that they wanted so
there's not going to be one single plan
for this we will we've historically used
our
multi-service centers and places like in
the you know the health department
clinics but if we need to set up a
special clinic we will consider doing
that if we have to come up with mobile
vans to go into certain neighborhoods
we'll figure out a way to do that
we're good these aren't things that we
haven't done before we made to do them
at a scale
we've not done before and there will
certainly there'll be something that's
going to come up and nobody thought of
we'll figure it out and we'll get the
job done thank you
and if i can emphasize just like we
learned the first time around with
testing
we want to make sure for example on the
on testing we wanted to make sure that
testing was provided in vulnerable at
risk
low-income communities the same thing
with this vaccine
it's important for the city
uh and for us to be advocating and doing
everything on our part
to make sure that communities and uh
groups that have been disproportionately
impacted
uh low-income minority communities
communities of color
uh that they are in the in the
the first part of this as much as
possible
um because that's where i think we need
to focus on where the disproportional
impact has occurred
and make sure that once you get past the
health care providers and your first
responders
that these communities that have been
disproportionately impacted communities
of color low-income communities
that they are right there in the
mainstream of distribution
so that has to be very intentional that
has to be a part of the matrix
right now at the very beginning as a
part of the planning
and not come in on the back end
otherwise
uh you know more people will be impacted
and more people will die so
i i just want to say that at the very
beginning before you even before one
vaccine is this is disseminated and it's
important for the state
it's important for the state to be in
tune with that
to make sure that the distribution uh
once you get past your first
uh your healthcare providers and first
responders that these communities
communities of color
where there's been a disproportionate
impact that those vaccines are
distributed uh to those communities at
the very beginning
hi there like a little party with kprc
um mayor i have two questions for you
but i just wanted to touch
up on something dr purse just said um
you sort of touched on this in your last
answer but will the city have its own
supply then of coronovirus vaccine
and if so is that coming from the
federal government is it coming from the
state will you have to compete with
other areas
a good question so the vaccine is coming
right from the manufacturers
the federal government is in this is
working with the states to tell the
manufacturers who to send it to
and so this goes on with this
prioritization list that the governor
put out today
and it is not a completely fleshed out
pride is that what you saw today is
is uh really its group party group 1a
and we don't know how many numbers
that's going to go up to yet so this is
you know the first pass identifying
those are the you know
the front of the line but i'm sure the
governor's office will be
fleshing out further priorities as time
goes on
and you sort of in the answer question
so yeah we will we fully anticipate
receiving vaccine at some point directly
from the manufacturer
thank you and then you sort of touched
on this as well but in terms of
obviously there's the group of
prioritized folks who will get it first
for average people in the community who
may not be part of that group uh any
estimate as to how long
down the line it'll be in terms of weeks
months before they are able to get the
vaccine
good question part of that obviously
goes to how quickly the manufacturers
can produce vaccine and you've been
seeing you know in the news that they're
talking about millions and millions of
doses that they're they're working on
producing
uh part of it goes how quickly it is
consumed
so the healthcare workers and how
quickly we can get it and how how
uh you know how many people take and i i
think that there's gonna be a pretty
high percentage of
healthcare workers that are going to
take it um i can assure you that the nun
is gonna go to waste there are
safeguards in place that none go to
waste
now when we talk we hear people like dr
fauci and others at the federal level
talk about when the
you know the sort of the average person
would be able to get it there i'm
hearing
april is a common answer to that
question but i would put a little
asterisk with that answer because we're
gonna have to wait and see
you know how fast it comes out and how
fast it's consumed
thank you and then two questions for the
mayor um mayor in some communities the
wednesday before thanksgiving is
traditionally a night that a lot of
people
go out for drinks or partying uh even
though bars technically are not supposed
to be open in harris county uh some have
transitioned
into restaurant service are you
concerned about big crowds on wednesday
night and will you order any stepped-up
enforcement
well we're certain and the answer to
your question is yes because there are a
number of
bars that are now have been re
classified as restaurant
what i would say number one is you know
uh people also have to be responsible
for their own individual hate behavior
if you walk into any establishment
whether it's a restaurant whether it's a
bar that's now
a characterized as a restaurant whether
it's a um
any sort of venue and it's a large crowd
and people are but if it's a large crowd
you ought to turn around and walk out
that's number one and certainly if you
walk in and do any sort of place and you
see people in there with no mass on
and there's no social discipline then
you need to turn around and walk out
that's that's number one number two uh
yes i mean we will be monitoring the
situation as much as possible
um out there to try to um
enforce to the degree that we can but uh
it is important for people to exercise
individual responsibility
compare in my restaurants now is 75
capacity
so it's hard to distinguish when you
whether you're 75 or 100
when you're 75 you i mean
who's going to you know um make that
determination that you
you you're beyond your limit and then
now that many of the
the bars have reclassified as
restaurants
you know that makes it very difficult
for our firefighters police officers and
others who have so much other things
that they need to do
so it makes it difficult and that's why
individual responsibility becomes so
kingly important
and then sort of uh going off of that
final question for you is just about the
uh accountability wall the wall of shame
and the city's website i checked today
accounted 17 businesses around there
um i just wanted you to reflect did you
feel it ended up being effective or not
effective given where we are in the
pandemic you know i thought it was
because it came during that time we were
in uh in that june
that june period june july so i think
all of those measures helped
i think i think it did have a positive
it had a positive impact
and then let me just say this just
because the restaurant has the
has the right to go at 75 percent
there's nothing that says that you have
to go at 75
do you think going back to that though
do you think that any of those
businesses felt like they were ashamed
and that it changed any of their
behavior
i believe that it did i believe it did
based on the feedback that we were
getting based on the responses that i
was getting on social media
and the emails that we were receiving i
think it did have have a positive impact
and then i think what added to that and
let me thank the media just the fact
that you all reported on it
that i believe it did have a positive
impact so uh
i think it's a combination of things uh
the i think when people are hearing the
numbers and the number of people in
hospitals
okay i think all of it in combination i
don't think it's any one thing
but i think it's a combination of
factors and i still want to believe that
uh
if you provide people with the
information
uh and don't try to sanitize it just
provide it to people and provide
information to people
i think people will exercise their
common judgment they're smart enough to
say okay we got it
i would like to thank that dr perez my
question is to you
uh we are we are very happy to hear of
the
vaccine and vaccine vaccine but i want
you to
speak to why do we
hear this issue of mrn vaccine
and how different is it from the
different vaccine process and production
which has happened before and why are
they talking about
a synthetic chemically produced vaccine
and the need for caution because i'm
sure the population
wants to hear from you why that need for
caution
okay thanks that's a great question so
the mrna technology is a new technology
for vaccine production now a lot of the
traditional vaccine
techniques are being used with some of
the other manufacturers but the mrna
is a messenger rna and so a little bit
of
biology so you know dna it's a
double-stranded rna is single-stranded
it's a series of amino acids
that are basically it's like a genetic
code think of it almost like a barcode
for your cells it's a series of
of amino acids when in a particular
order tell your cells to do something
and so with this mrna vaccine
it basically functions almost
in its own right almost like a little
mini virus but what it tells the cell to
do
is to produce the proteins look just
exactly like the spike protein
on the surface of the coronavirus and so
as your cells start producing millions
of copies of the spike protein
your immune system recognizes that that
is not supposed to be here this is
something new this is not part of me
this is not supposed to be here and it
mounts a reaction to get rid of that
so then if you should later become
infected with the coronavirus that has
those same spike proteins on the outside
your immune system will recognize that
that's not supposed to be here
and then the cascade begins and all the
immune steps immune system so that then
the
the coronavirus gets destroyed
by your immune system only because it
has a spike protein on it that you
already told your immune system that
anything that has this
white protein on it destroy it so the
the messenger rna
is um it's a new technology it's
actually relatively brilliant
it is done as you said synthetically so
there's you know there's no other animal
proteins and sometimes when we get
allergic reactions
to um viruses and other medications
quite honestly
it's because some of those have other
animal proteins that our immune system
gets
we have an allergic reaction so there's
much less risk for it so it's quite
brilliant this new
technology and the fact that we can do
it is because of all the advances in
genome sequencing
which started you know a decade or two
ago
and we have now got to the point we can
actually create a messenger rna system
or a messenger rna to to tell your cells
to start producing a particular protein
to teach your immune system to seek and
destroy if you ever see it again
i think i understood
more when chief pena was talking in
spanish
then i understood the dialogue between
the two of you
which means press conference is over
[Laughter]
it was quite good it's not impossible
yeah let me let me just say happy
thanksgiving to everyone
uh i think his uh felice diel
de sava
you got it happy thanksgiving thank you